[Musique]
bonsoir marie-christine duniaud merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors en tant que médecin parce que vous
n'êtes évidemment pas un analyste
politique comment vous réagissez à cette
déclaration de jayen ball sonar
aujourd'hui bon ben c'est catastrophique
parce que en réalité c'est la réalité
c'est vraiment ce qui se passe ici au
brésil on a complètement perdu
absolument les rênes de l'épidémie on
n'arrive plus à rien faire les hôpitaux
sont saturés le service public aussi
bien que le service privé est
complètement saturé il ya une moyenne
d'occupation de l'ide de soins intensifs
qui tourne entre 95 et 100 %
d'occupation complète
il manque énormément de personnel nous
manque énormément de soignants bien sûr
donc beaucoup de lits de réanimation
mais pas seulement de lits dans les
services de réanimation mais de lits
dans les hôpitaux d'une façon générale
on a jusqu'à présent on arrive à 198
milles morts ce qui est énorme
le plus terrible c'est ce que ce sont
les chiffres officiels les chiffres
officieux on ne les connaît pas on n'a
pas les moyens d'y et connaître c'est ça
qui est ça qui est terrible
on a une moyenne de ces derniers jours
on avait une moyenne de 57 milk à
nouveau par jour c'est pareil tout est
très peu on n'a pas les moyens de tester
surtout dans les services publics les
services privés ites davantage c'est
tout à fait normal
ils ont plus de moyens mais les services
publics test très peu et quand il teste
on a les résultats dans 10 ans 12 15
jours voire 20 jours donc ces déchets
sont des chiffres qui sont absolument en
dessous de la réalité
nous ce qu'on voit aux magazines ce
qu'est ce qu'ils sont gays incroyable
c'est que j'ai un mal sonar ou quand il
déclare comme ça le brésil en faillite
cet après midi il dit je ne peux rien
faire
attribuant cette crise a à ce virus le
site alimenté par la presse ça paraît
incroyable ce qu'il croise et il dit
je ne sais pas si le crois je pense
qu'il devra
que c'est quelqu'un qui n'est pas très
sérieux disons au minimum est en réalité
le brésil avait déjà un déficit
budgétaire énorme avant avant qu'il
n'arrive qui s'est aggravée lors de la
première année lors de l'année 2018
et puis boum à la crise en 2019 qui a
commencé la crise monétaire qui a
commencé à vraiment faire la montre et a
montré son vrai visage en 2010 neuf mois
s'est aggravée en 2020 avait à cause du
virus mais c'est pas à cause du virus
comme d'origine est en faillite
on se souvient avant les fêtes un des
images de la plage de coquettes
copacabana noire de monde on connaît
évidemment aux états unis les faits
france give him
est ce que le pain le pire est encore à
venir au brésil
et oui tout simplement parce qu'il n'y a
pas de véritable confinement même quand
les autorités déterminent et d'exil qui
a un confinement et à par confinement
les gens continuent à aller à la plage
les gens continuent ils ont fait la fête
pendant qu'il mois de décembre et
continue à la faire ça c'est terrible
les place bondée de monde les gens se ce
cinglant revers n'importe où dans l'est
dans les transports en commun et c'est
donc à pas trop finement bien souvent et
gagnent des bois madame comment vous
vous l'expliquer parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya vous l'avez dit vous les avez
cités ces morts au brésil ça veut dire
que la population n'a pas conscience
finalement de la dangerosité de ce virus
au brésil et une grande
il ya une grande partie de la population
qui n'a pas continent qui n'a absolument
pas confiance qui n'y croient pas qu'il
ne veut pas y croire et une autre partie
de cette population qui ne peut pas
faire autrement que de travailler mais
même comme ça c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas obligé qu'elle respecte les gestes
barrières bien souvent elles ne les
respectent pas non plus donc il ya un
manque de conscience de la part de la de
la majorité de la population je dirais
ici alors évidemment le brésil et le
vaccin qui semblerait aussi être la
seule solution la cour suprême a
d'ailleurs rendu la vaccination
obligatoire avec des sanctions pour les
réfractaires mais
il semblerait que chez vous au brésil et
également beaucoup de retard on n'a pas
franchement commencer à vacciner n'est
ce pas seulement pas absolument pas
c'est toujours d'un coup il ya des tas
de négociations qui sont toujours en
cours en plus de ça depuis hier on sait
qu'il manque énormément de matériel pour
vacciner
pas seulement les vaccins bien sûr
puisque les négociations continuent à
être un coup mais il manque aussi du
matériel il n'ya pas te ya pas assez de
seringue a pas assez d'aiguillés enfin
gardien c'est un peu c'est dramatique et
on imagine que justement le président
brésilien dont on parle elle n'arrange
pas les choses puisque l'huile se
présente sans complexe comme anti vaccin
avec des propos assez étonnant
d'ailleurs sur sur le vaccin
oui oui tout à fait il a dit que s'ils
se faisaient vacciner il ressemblerait
un crocodile ou un truc comme ça je me
rappelle plus les lauréats des
crocodiles et les hommes au raid et des
voix de femmes at il dit jayen rôle
sommerau sur le vexin on imagine que ça
n'arrange pas les choses pour promouvoir
cette campagne future de vaccination
d'un non parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui vont être contre le vaccin
simplement parce qu'ils vont avoir peur
ça faut reconnaître que c'est la réalité
un peu partout dans le monde aussi c'est
pas seulement spécifique au brésil mais
en plus de ça il ya comme n'aura pas
beaucoup de vaccins ya quand même deux
cent vingt millions d'habitants issus
brésil dieu les les
les prix des vaccins même le astrazeneca
qui se fait le moins cher de tous a vu
les prix des vaccins
il est impossible qu'on vaccine 200
millions de personnes
ça c'est impossible il faut reconnaître
que ça va pas ça va pas brider sa pourra
pas se taire en plus de ça je crois que
les gens ils vont ils vont les gens qui
ont une certaine et celle des moyens
disons des gens qui appartiennent à une
classe moyenne et moyenne supérieure ils
vont faire vacciner ils auront les
moyens même de se faire vacciner dans le
privé n'est par contre dans le service
public il y aura chez pas 1% de la
population qui va se faire vacciner
d'ici merci en tout cas marie christine
du nude avoir été avec nos médecins g
1 liste au consulat français de rio de
janeiro merci de nous avoir expliqué la
situation inquiétante au brésil